hierzu recken ok habe ich bin in der
schlucht jona da was geht hier so anni
und heute gibt es einen durch den treff
ist mit keinem geringeren als 100 95
grad
das werk gute idee wenn ich mir hätte
bis in minecraft let's play mache das
war eine mischung aus ironie und matten
job ich habe jetzt schon fast ein voll
ist equipment denn ich habe an einer
kiste dran der treffen die aufgabe
nämlich keine vielleicht kann ich essen
ich habe leider keine wie eine
fluglinien delight beschaffen ich bringe
man die treppe und probiere dem hier zu
recken ok habe ich bin unten der
schlucht
ok ich stecke jetzt gerade sowieso auch
die kugel noch zu töten und dann haben
geschafft aber aber leute das werde ich
nicht schaffen okay okay dann sogleich
wieder freundlich auf deine bananen zum
fest eine banane mit honig bestellt da
sind wie man freunde da vorne ist man
homeboy 195 km 55 laufen hinterher
ich komme mit dir mit noch einer hat ihn
hab ihn es ist eine minute
wir marschieren jetzt so richtig durch
jetzt sehen wir was was so schön ist
bestellt hast musst ich hab gar mit
einem gepackten banane mit der banane
bestellt
was ist bauen knusprig und läuft mit dem
korb durch den wald das beruht
ein richtiges alter 50 macht auch pvp
kämpfe kommen wir gern herunter okay wir
noch nie gewesen ist dass auf jedem
server
nein ich weiß ehrlich nicht wieder
hochkommt als auch schon angefangen bis
jetzt ich schaffe es was den weg nach
oben geschafft als würdest du meinen
ganzen bruder auf hätten bilden
ich bin runter gefallen
wen wählen ist vincent hat mir reaktiven
das war nämlich auch sehr lustig wir
waren's noch unterwegs
pass auf uns zurück kommen die bist du
ich wurde getauscht wurde nicht nur ein
rein rein
damit ist nur dass du noch ja ich wurde
zum glück aus meiner misslichen
misslichen lage wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen glück aber wir können ja noch
was tolles interesses einfach wie sehr
oder wie du jetzt eine banane essen also
ich werde meine ware günstig vorspeise
ich werde die zuerst in meinen mund
steckt ein fortschreiten die mit
leckereien hier und sind zwei leute im
wasser
ich weiß es nicht es geht aber auch die
anderen
aber ein bisschen was zu essen habe ich
noch warum stimmt dialekt glaube ich und
sein kollege beschützt ihn jetzt ist er
was ist passiert
ein schuss lenkt den ihr was mit dem
anderen passiert muss gewarnt werden
ich erinnere mich noch an diese
wunderschöne bedways wunder schließlich
die leute vor mir umgefallen sind aber
so was habe also er habe ja gar nicht
nötig die normale kids so was gibt es
auch da meine kleine schwester
terrorisiert mit ihren beruf die ganze
zeit möchten werden kannst du dir
erklären
okay es ist ja am arsch lecken abschluss
freut kommt schon ihre kollegen angel
spieler endlich gestern bis fünf leute
es wäre etwas wie übrigens auch gerade
eine sexy runde
wer würde würdest du für viel geld genau
dafür wie viel das ist eine sehr schöne
runde denn ich wurde gerade eben gewinnt
zeit wurde vom server gebannt sehe ich
gerade meinen wirst überall nur hater
und so ist der echte fable crafter ja
ich muss in kraft er kommt in den chor
kraft ekliger verfestigt ich drücke mich
einfach vor meinem pc herunter gerade
warum es bis das ist bigott erdfall
punkt ich hab noch wenig ich immer
weniger ja was wenig
okay aber ich habe meine porsche walter
die andere leute sollen schnell sterben
dass wir ins netz kommen
30 sekunden das schaffe ich auf jeden
fall schon die ganze zeit alleine banane
banani wird so lecker werden ich sag dir
das weil ich glaube da ist nämlich
bisschen banane mit honig übertrug
drüber und dazu göttlichen lächeln
köstlichen was hamburg hamburg r die
luft in hamburg denn das war intelligent
intelligenz kein team und durch das ist
eine neue arena von uns kennst du schon
wow spieler auf dem server was gut war
dies ein neuer alter bitte dies dann
habe ich mich schon etwas aufgezeigt ich
habe extra vom ersten blick wert ist
eine milliarde weist das herz auf ich
bin oder der andere kommt gerade der
andere es tatsächlich relativ gut
equipment damit auch bewusst hoffe ich
mal arbeitet er hat einen dingens nur
ein eisen schwert und altenburg auch in
allen städten
[ __ ] it was mit den anderen kollegen ich
weiß nicht wer lebt noch
der steht da hinten auf warum irgendwie
steht also im kaukasus an
ok ich hab' ja das finde ich es mit
chinas der jetzt hier so auf
emilian was du musst es schaffen
ich gebe mein bestes für uns was denn
jetzt los
aber jetzt kommt der andere an was bist
du für das netz richtige pussy runde fix
pack oder klappt es auch und jetzt alte
das ist ja richtig weil diese andere
team
du spielst an die letzte die letzte
[ __ ] wartet wo bist du hier mit van
der wissel und damit sagen das war's für
heute
ich bin 61